ladies and gentlemen welcome back to the
GameSpot stage uh you know in the month
leading up to e3 there are a lot of
leaks a lot of announcements of games
coming out that you like maybe they
really wanted to do a split make a
splash at e3 but ah the leaks they
thwarted them this next game was not
leaked was a big splashy yesterday at
the Sony press conference it's infamous
first light and joining me on stage I've
made Fox the game director from Sucker
Punch and Laura Bailey the voice actress
who plays fetch in the DLC welcome you
too so excited to have you here talk
about first light you guys have been
talking about it publicly for oh yeah
all right so this the first this big DLC
for infamous second son featuring fetch
one of the great allies you have as
Desmond in she is awesome and her power
is so awesome so alright let's first
let's set the stage first light you know
where do we come in in terms of the
infamous second son timeline so first
light is actually a prequel to infamous
second son it's the origin story where
we see how fetch got her powers and went
from kind of this girl next door to the
kind of badass weirdo we meet in second
son takes place well she was pretty
except how would you describe fetch well
if you're teleca's sort of origin story
that's kind of dark like she did not
have a good time and we saw in the
trailer you know it's sort of it starts
off and she's in detention she's locked
up and but even before the DUP got her
their hands on fetch she wasn't having a
good time of it no I mean and that was
you know in that little flash you got an
infamous second son you saw you know her
parents kind of betrayed her and she ran
off and got a little addicted to some
stuff yeah so
it definitely takes place on those kind
of those hard days on the streets and
also in this kind of high alpine prison
called curtin k station where they put
anybody with superpowers they lock them
up so that's to me it's kind of an
interesting part of the franchise
because you always really want to go
there in second Sun to see what it was
like inside of that yeah how's your
prison well let's take a look at this
trailer we showed yesterday or b-roll
you guys have brought so here's a look
at that Alpine setting yeah now this
doesn't look like a place that you would
have a lot of freedom to move around
unless maybe you got rid of those
concrete shackle you know those those
crazy cuffs yeah so what does the player
end up so I mean you know one of the
great things about a DLC like this with
a different protagonists then the main
game is you get to tell a whole
different story you get to set the stage
in an entirely different way and sort of
the player experience is then radically
different so what does fetches
experience here in the dup prison there
there are some details and I'd love to
tell you about that we're kind of being
a little heads down but I can't tell you
the big point of difference is that
while Delson had the ability to draw
neon out of out of the city yeah and
fuel his powers fetched can draw neon as
well but her powers are totally
different and that creates for a very
different play experience and mastering
those powers is I think what you're
gonna get excited about that's what I
get excited about it being able to use
them I was excited to see the difference
in fighting style between the two of
them totally yeah fetch is much faster
more physical as you can tell so you can
punch a hole in your skull that's why
I'm at a safe room here of a few feet
which is barely out when of course not
help me at all where you be to be
actually laser from neon power I one of
the moments in infamous second son that
I think is so powerful is that moment
when you do get to first move around
with the neon powers because so quick
it's so freeing it's it's an incredible
rush and you know that sensation I
imagine is captured in a lot of fetches
gameplay but then that's also set
against this imprisonment so
you know how do you sort of manage that
tone you know between that bedroom that
like neon freedom lightness yeah neon
well as you might imagine it's fetch
wants to get out of out of lockdown I
don't know if you you've been in prison
uh myself no I have I have not been
impressed actually
yeah I've been to Alcatraz now I stayed
a night there was not was you know of my
own volition but well fetch wants out
and and their power is actually this
kind on the inside baseball bet on I
didn't from his second son yeah we made
a bunch of neon powers and we had to
dial them back because they were just
kicking the crap out of all the other
powers people only wanted to play with
me totally overpowered so when we gave
fetch and we were making her moves
we had no shackles they could be totally
a badass so everything that we couldn't
put in and second son we gave to fetch
and it's all the high watermark
abilities and you use them inside of you
know these environments sorry I'm being
cagey about no I I totally understand
your position you know we basically like
cut the trailer to go off of and you
guys are being coy about other stuff but
I feel yeah well Laura I want to talk to
you about voicing fetch because you had
our prolific voice actress and you've
been in like an incredible variety of
stuff you know from voicing Dragon Ball
Z characters to chun-li in Street
Fighter 4 to Katherine in the game
Katherine which I gotta say is a huge
favorite amongst the folks at GameSpot
it really does so you know Sonic the
Hedgehog characters like you've been all
over the place but you know a lot of his
characters are not human women right so
what was you know did you sort of find
any kind of identification here with
fetch that you maybe didn't when you're
playing like blaze the cat's right
well she she definitely comes from more
human place than than many of my
characters and she's an adult you know
and she's dealing with a lot of issues
that a lot of them my characters in past
projects wouldn't even come close to so
there's a grittiness to her that I don't
get to experience with other characters
which was really amazing I was so
excited when we got to come back for the
DLC and and see what made her become
almost closed off and not trusting to
other people and you get to see the
development event which is really cool
so how many months did you spend as a
drug addict or in prison to prepare for
this role yeah I'm actually curious to
know like you know when you came on it
as to be two voice fetch did you know
there was gonna be this sort of bonus
adventure or is that something they came
back it to you and her like hey listen
we got this plan no idea I was stoked
when I got the phone call people fans
really like fetch we've listened to
feedback after second son came out and
Laura's really fun to work with and very
talented so we thought this is perfect
to make this standalone story which
actually you don't need second son to
play it's a standalone game in its
entirety its own story however however
yeah you do have a copy a second sign of
her you get extra content that's that's
pretty good cool yeah I like it I may
have gotten a little detail on that and
it is pretty cool yeah you're on the
inside Laura yeah do you find yourself
you know there are certain games you
play and you you know you get really
into the mindset of the game and you
start like you know if it's GTA 5 you
start thinking like maybe that yellow
line in the middle of the road I don't
need to pay attention to it you play you
know a infamous second son and you start
thinking like yeah I'm just gonna go up
that building and then like cross that
rooftop and like I do you find yourself
like looking at neon signs a little
differently now looking at everything a
little different now I know it's it's
really depressing when you can't just
hop over a building no problem just sit
in traffic life
real world and that's why video games I
worried about that after infamous one
where you look for every electrical
outlet and I kept thinking like how many
five-year-olds right now are just
looking at that outlet thinking that
it's food King what can i what can I
draw for that
well yeah cuz you do you look at the
world as power you know where as you and
I might look at Donuts as a source of
our conduit ability are you leaving me
out of that thanks for mentioning that
by the way and not bringing any had
really appreciate that
well first light you know this is sort
of falling in a I don't know if I'd say
it's a trend but certainly something
that we've seen it from other DLC from
other games when it's a whole new
protagonist a whole new perspective and
I just I love it when you get that
chance to inhabit a game world from a
different direction so so psyched to
talk to you guys about infamous first
light and you know standalone DLC for
infinite second son do we have a release
date for it yet yeah August 2014 for
$14.99 in store
low low yes very cool very cool Laura
thank you so much for coming on so much
Nate's thank you so much talking first
light as much as you could I look
forward to hearing more about it in the
coming months and have a great a three
show you guys don't you appreciate it